heftiges
besseres bis es ist eine win win beute
gehört genauso zum winter ohne spaß ich
kann das alles weg und der anteil kam er
ich bin richtig begeistert
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute etwas
richtig tolles ist sieht wunderschön aus
und es schmeckt sehr sehr gut wir machen
ein pistazien paris brest das ist ein
brand teig der ist rund man stellt ihn
auf da kommt dann pistazien creme rein
und dann hat er dazu auf wie vor richtig
lecker ich habe euch wie immer alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben hier unten in die
infobox und ich starte jetzt direkt mit
dem brand teil gerade so anfängt trauen
sich da nicht so gerne daran aber ich
muss sagen es ist super easy zeigt auch
nicht wirklich schritt für schritt wie
das funktioniert ich habe jetzt hier
meine hochland von ihr könnt auch
einfach einen topf den ich finde hier
könnt ihr immer besser rein schauen
durch die kamera und für dieses rezept
also grundsätzlich nämlich nur wasser
verbrannt tag für dieses rezept nehmen
wir aber milch und wasser
das kommt jetzt hier direkt mit rein
so wie jemand rausholen hier und dann
brauchen wir hier diesmal ein bisschen
zucker nicht viel eine prise salz die
macht den geschmack noch schön rund und
da könnt ihr dann auch schon butter
dazugeben die dachte nämlich ruhig darin
schmelzen und sobald die butter
geschmolzen ich bin jetzt hier bei stufe
acht von neun sobald die butter
geschmolzen ist geben wir in einem
schwung das mit dazu und dann müssen wir
den teig abbrennen aber dazu sage ich
euch gleich noch was
[Musik]
ihr erhaltet dann einen teigklumpen
wichtig ist dass wir wirklich zügig
rührt damit dass ich keine nähe mester
nester in drin bilden und dann den teig
immer wieder bewegen nicht stehen lassen
also ich habe jetzt eine beschichtete
pfanne und dann werdet ihr diesen
typischen weißen belag diese typische
weiße koste die man sonst bekommt nichts
sehen es funktioniert aber trotzdem nie
gesagt dass es vielleicht noch für
einige ungewohnt weil von brenntag kennt
man das dass ich da so weißer belag an
so koste bildet und das ist eben in
einer beschichteten pfanne nicht so und
da könnt ihr euch einfach an die zeit so
ein bisschen richten also nach gefühl
manches mal sind aber so drei bis
maximal vier minuten und beim abbrennen
bewegt man einfach dass luft im teig
bleibt und dadurch geht der teig später
im backofen richtig auf das kind die
wahrscheinlich von windbeuteln und so
ist das heute auch bei dem rezept dann
nehme ich mir direkt schon mal eine
rührschüssel bzw die rührschüssel von
meiner küchenmaschine ich mache nämlich
mit der maschine weiter ihr könnt aber
auch euer handrücken gerät benutzen
sprachfehler oder ihr macht uns einfach
mit dem arm das dauert zwar tut auch ein
bisschen linie an den muttis aber das
kriegt er auch hin
[Musik]
ich habe den brand tag jetzt noch mal so
ein bisschen hoch gedrückt das hilft
einfach dass ich das besser verteilt das
ein bisschen schneller abkühlt und so
lag das jetzt zehn minuten bei mir rum
damit es eben nicht ganz so heiß wenn
jetzt die eier dazu kommen ich finde es
ganz ganz wichtig dass ihr jetzt die
eier nacheinander ein rührt weil wenn
ihr alles auf einmal rein gibt das ist
da passt die konsistenz dann einfach
nicht mehr ich nehme jetzt hier auch bei
meiner maschine den knethaken mit den
zweit aber nie dran wir können dann
nämlich richtig schön ob die ränder
mitnehmen und jetzt wie gesagt erst eins
nach dem anderen ein rühren dass du
heute 20 30 sekunden ich habe es damals
gab es erstmalig brand 18 gemacht bei
uns im café in der küche und das mit
einem holz dafür gemacht weil ich hatte
solche arme schmerzen aber es
funktioniert viele wege führen nach rom
und in dem ich stufe 2 von 12 also
wirklich schön langsam einrühren und
wenn alle vier eier dann drin sind dann
kann man weitermachen
[Musik]
so die feier habe ich jetzt ein
gearbeitet zwischendurch habe das gefühl
es verbindet sich gar nicht und alles zu
flüssig so ganz viele kleine stücke aber
dann müsste man einfach weitermachen
gerade wenn ihr das per hand rührt immer
weiter machen irgendwann verbindet sich
die masse der wcm einen spritzbeutel und
eine lokale vorne dran die hat bei mir
einen durchmesser von neun millimeter
ist jedoch 10 mm gehen ich will es aber
nicht zu groß machen denn ihr müsst sich
vorstellen dass der teig im open auch
richtig schön aufgeht da gebe ich jetzt
die komplette brandzeit masserey dies
übrigens sehr klebrig also wirklich
nicht wundern dass soll so gebe ich
jetzt komplett rein und gleich zeichne
ich mir einfach einen kreis auf meinen
backpapier und dann zeige ich euch hilfe
das ganze auf spritzen
[Musik]
mein kreis hat einen durchmesser von 20
zentimetern und ihr spritzt quasi zwei
kreise einmal um den ring herum der 20
zentimeter ist innen noch einen ring und
der dritte der darf auch so minimal
dicker sein der kommt dann oben drüber
es ist ein sehr sehr fester teig daher
habt unbedingt richtig gute spritzbeutel
das war so meinen der test ob ich meine
spritzbeutel im shop aufnehmen oder
nicht und da platzt gar nichts aber
sonst wenn ihr so spritzbeutel hat bei
denen etwas platz dann ärgert ihr euch
nur so ich habe es hier noch wasser und
mandelblättchen ich sehe das auch ganz
oft dass man brand noch mal mit einem
verwirrten eine streng ich finde man
kann sich das sparen wir haben gleich
bei der konditor käme auch schon wieder
ein die daher nehmt ihr einfach nur
wasser messen und jetzt nicht so rein
drücken sondern nicht so ganz vorsichtig
mit dem pinsel benetzen und dann kommen
da noch gehobelte mandeln obendrauf und
der ring wird gebacken bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze brauchst du circa 40
minuten ich verrate euch die genau da
zeitgleich bei mir aber jeder backofen
backen nach daher achtet auf jeden fall
auch auf die farbe dass er nicht zu
dunkel wird
[Musik]
während der brandtag jetzt im ofen ist
machen wir weiter mit der creme
patissier bei paris das ist eigentlich
so dass man so eine art praliné masse
macht wie nehme gleich unsere pistazien
creme und daher entfällt dieser schritt
ist es ganz entspannt heute und wir
beginnen jetzt direkt mit dem pudding
also die konditor creme auf deutsch und
dafür brauchen wir zuallererst ja viele
sträuben sich immer dagegen aber er
braucht sich keine sorgen machen die
einheit für eine mega konsistenz und
dadurch das erwärmt wird braucht euch
überhaupt keine sorgen machen ich trenne
jetzt einmal weiß von eigelb gibt zucker
und vanille extrakt damit rein verrührt
das und dann geht's weiter
[Musik]
also ich sag das jetzt hier nur zwei
minuten dem schnee und ihm auch damit
dass vom bist schön cremig dk wird aber
nur ein bisschen und dann gebe ich da
auch schon mehr mit reinen damit das
schön klümpchen frei nochmal verrührt
wird und mein herz ist natürlich noch
ausgeschaltet
das ist jetzt eine masse ließ auch
perfekt hättest ausgeschaltet da kommt
es mich rein und dann wird es einmal
erwärmt ihr müsst es nicht direkt hoch
kochen oder sowas hab doch immer gerne
euren teigs aber am start weil nicht
dass die milch irgendwie unten anbrennt
aber ich muss erst mal fangen bei mir
brennt keine wirklich an und dann wenn
es so warm ist bz muss wie gesagt nicht
hochkochen wenn es warm ist gehen wir
diese eingeht masserey und lassen das
unter ständigem rühren richtig schön
eindecken das dauert auch nicht lange 23
minuten und dann ist es fertig und wenn
die gestern habt kommt ganz zum schluss
die mutter hat mit rein die schmilzt
aber dann in der rest setze
[Musik]
so meine konditor creme ist fertig ich
habe sie in eine saubere schüssel
umgefüllt direkt an der oberfläche
frischhaltefolie drauf gegeben damit
sich keine haut bildet und jetzt wird
das komplette seite gelegt damit es
einmal abkühlen kann sowas könnte
übrigens auch ganz gut am vortag
vorbereiten oder erwartet die zeit so
ein bisschen das ist ja auch kein
problem gleich gibt übrigens mein ofen
in wenigen sekunden das waren jetzt
genau 40 minuten noch einen kleinen tipp
zum brand tag ihr könnt das ganze im
ofen mit seiner leicht geöffneten tür
einfach 15 20 minuten abkühlen lassen
also im ofen anschließend rausholen und
auf zimmertemperatur komplett abkühlen
lassen damit eben nicht in sich zusammen
sagt und bitte bitte nicht die ofentür
öffnen während das ganze bald also die
ersten 40 minuten dürfte sie nicht
öffnen und wir sehen uns gleich wieder
[Musik]
der kranz ist fertig gebacken der ist
auch schön abgekühlt und jetzt machen
wir erstmal weiter mit unserer creme ich
habe jetzt immer warme butter und ihr
wisst ja vielleicht aus anderen videos
von mir wenn ihr zimmer warme butter
wirklich lange genug aufschlag dann
ändert es nicht nur konsistenz sondern
auch mundgefühl und geschmack also alles
im i und deswegen ist es ganz ganz
wichtig dass ihr euch dafür zeit nehmen
mit der küchenmaschine so ungefähr vier
minuten einem handrührgerät würde ich
jetzt sagen 67 minuten vielleicht sogar
acht also das ist richtig schön hell
cremig wird und anschließend gebe ich
auch schon den abgekühlten pudding dazu
immer so schlückchen weil seit ich schon
fast geschafft immer so purple und dann
soll das einfach eine homogene masse
werde
[Musik]
zuerst gesehen wie hell cremig die
butter masse war die pudding massa
einfach nur kurz ein rührender box gar
nicht mehr so lange einfach so lange bis
eine homogene masse wird und jetzt fragt
ihr euch wahrscheinlich posiert ist ein
teil davon da kommt natürlich jetzt mit
der cookies cream bis tokio und die ist
extrem intensiv dafür brauchen wir gar
nicht so viel es gibt das jetzt einfach
außer für weise mit dazu und dann sollte
sich die creme schön grün färben weil
das auge isst ja auch mit drin war das
noch ganz kurz ein ich will mir das in
einen spritzbeutel und ich glaube ich
nehme heute so eine französische stern
würde das ist die mit ganz vielen
kleinen zacken einer meiner lieblings
tönen und dann wird der kann es also der
brand kampf einfach nur vorsichtig
aufgeschnitten und dann gehen wir die
creme daran die muss jetzt auch nicht
können die ist nämlich komplett fertig
und kann sofort verwertet werden stört
sie bis dahin geben nur noch ein und
dann ist es fertig
[Musik]
wir probieren jetzt parallel rest in
peace teams sei also sieht so aus
gesunden mit platz drei ja das ist ja
auch eigentlich das richtige
französische patient richtig schön aber
das nicht so schlecht mein handy
nahaufnahme auf dass der anstieg des
hammer durch sonne ja die nummer der
intralogistik schön
heftig ja da wird man direkt rein
meisten mich verleitet bis dazu jetzt
die gabel zur seite zu legen und mit der
hand zu entnehmen ist hat sich das ja
nicht aber das ist doch toll dass
trotzdem viele genau da ist unsere queen
drin unsere touchscreen und an sich
eigentlich sehr einfach wenn man sich
vorstellt wie aufwendig das bist du so
ein bienenstich ihr wegen dem an den
umlagen ja ich weiß nicht wieso wir
tauschen heute die partie sind den enden
der kann was ich möchte dann schon
ich möchte ist aber ich möchte auch das
ist so kühl ist jetzt kommt jetzt ganz
frisches und feiere ich auch erst mal
dachte kennt zu kalt sein das ganze ist
also ja finde ich auch früher
erfrischung also nutze aufklärung es ist
jetzt gerade der nächste tag und das
konnte jetzt über nacht richtig schön
können ihr könnt noch sofort servieren
das ist gar kein problem aber wir haben
ist einfach das organisatorischen
gründen jetzt das probieren können trotz
und wind wird genauso ein windbeutel hat
aber so next level also richtig dass ich
selbst gemacht schmeckt besser und nach
so sport prior ich kann das alles
bekommt diese diese themen darin diese
pisten sind wie wenn ich max frisch das
ist ja bei den pudding mit pistazien
creme und der halle schon im antaike
paar mehr ich bin richtig begeistert ich
weiß ich weiß also wie das schmeckt ich
weiß die band schmeckt und wie diese
creme schmeckt aber dessen verbindung
leute macht das im nahverkehr megal ich
hab's gesehen ich habe das innerhalb der
kredit gehabt gar nicht schwer im magen
mega lecker mit die pistazie ja auch die
mangel nicht verzichten ist sogar aus
oder machen selber das richtig
langweilig meine stimmung ist wirklich
langweile ja es gibt noch es so ist
einfach die man geben dem ganzen noch
mal so richtig schön ich habe mir von
dem unternehmer zum giganten nächsten
rezept ja ganz gefasst machen
[Musik]